[Music]
oh my god oh my god oh my god I lost the
sub damn it
about your hit very slowly 49 million oh
my god alright I'm going out for a quick
run I'm really excited to be finally
we're working at getting back on my
schedule hopefully I won't fall again
[Music]
I just realize how [ __ ] stupid I just
looked doing that
I'm not Casey nice that let's just get
that clear okay so Michael lives here
somewhere he's been taking this shark
game way too seriously he doesn't know
I'm coming so I'm gonna try and sneak up
on him and see if he's wearing the shirt
or not
I can't see I'm gonna get shot
Oh Sammy you're wearing the shirt how
was it [ __ ] power
hey this basic thanks
besides the Michaelmas I'll see you
later Michael you love Romanian I will
get you keep your blinds closed I will
get you oh man good exercise good [ __ ] I
don't know what to go by I'm not the one
moving him I swear to God I just want to
be in the vlog parents I love the vlogs
Berta boy I'm a big subscriber big fan I
lava
a lot ken comes today he's the guest
first game pewdiepie whoops
spoilers oh my gosh and I'm in charge
can you can tell I having to record a
Peter
proper Peter private in the world for
[ __ ] sake I missed it 49 million 49
million subscribers that's more than you
will ever get oh my god
thank you guys that's great that's crazy
we're going 50 million eggs something
big is gonna happen on 50 million let me
tell you thank you all so much for being
subscribers that's [ __ ] awesome
I can't feel I missed it I was working
on this stupid vertigo graph I'm gonna
add the colors have to be correct
all right tsunami and mines they're
going outside to have some lunch and
Gabba
what are you doing [ __ ] weirdo like a
gob oh he's crazy he's gone too far
[Music]
all right
finding anything good there your nasta
Gail I'm gonna completely I don't know
real do some shopping I'm really tired
everyone's looking at me I realized I
look really strange with this camera
oh yeah in my collar yeah
yeah I think I get it leave a comment if
you like it I'm gonna buy it anyway
alright I got a lot of cool stuff the
problem is I can't wear any of it stupid
Swedish thing it's really hard to wear
the same shirt every day I didn't think
it would be this hard especially because
I like dressing up that's the main thing
I'm like Brad and Michael they don't
care they're slobs alright Bo but I'm a
fashion icon look at me why are you
laughing do you like that I'll buy two
actually I think someone is jealous on
my new glasses
yeah you're jealous someone's at the
door
oh who is it by the door that was too
sexy for the peopie chat what do you
think about my shirt ken so basically we
have to wear these shirts every single
day Michael and Brad has one but Michael
is playing it so seriously because we're
Swedish Swedish boy in LA yeah well
they're my [ __ ] okay okay we can [ __ ]
with the shirts you see they did this
they did this stupid penis thing the
thing is I can't [ __ ] with their shirt
directly so you will have to [ __ ] with
their shirt I'll pay you
so so it doesn't seem like you're a
[ __ ] oh my god this is my my that's the
most we've ever seen it would stop when
the time comes you will [ __ ] with my
whole shirt whatever horrible [ __ ] you
can put on it I want you to put on it
Wow Wow look who it is
I pay pen to talk with my chair because
I'm tired of dishes Michael taking it
too serious listen look when the time
comes I will
police grip them and you will grab them
we can pinioned that yeah well Homs
already talked with this show yeah yeah
the word of attack is Berta boat okay
when you hear that a bridge down
operation Berta boat begins
[Music]
[Applause]
start moving that's like oh my god Ken
are you the gas you're gonna be on the
show
wait why are you here
and um just so you guys know I get a
veto for filming scare PewDiePie I don't
have to wear this shirt for that to stop
commenting about it okay
[Music]
yeah no they don't count here's the
first one they don't count no that
doesn't count
and then they - I didn't even know she
was filming that no and then the third
vlog another strike I'm being filmed all
the time I'll rewrite like 10 times
harder for me today hey that's just part
of the rolls let the rolls of the rules
and they're very simple by the way I
asked you viewers can you see if I think
it's pretty much I think that's right
tonight it's right [ __ ] there you
[ __ ] if you can
so that's full strikes let's make the
rule now yeah you must have 25% of the
pledge 25 yeah but that's Michael you
know that that's a horrific ly offensive
symbol right I just know that I made it
that's pretty
oh my thought I'm Raina no he's Romanian
oh yeah right I have a present for you
yay it's my wedding to wear hey which
one I don't even want to touch
[Music]
season three I'm in the woods help me I
can't literally can't see anything are
spook you at red what's up Michael
hungry
you know Felix's go favorite I got
Salomon over here you want some salmon
[Music]
I'm the star shut up
why was it done talk to me how do I look
I want to see myself in the viewfinder
damn I look good dude
[ __ ] I look like it's already right
this is not thank you for watching I
have known
[Music]